movie news always movie news well in the
world of the rape of my childhood
Platinum Dunes otherwise known as
Michael Bay is set to produce the
long-awaited reboot of Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Orion visioning whatever
and the subscriber of mine penguin oh
one two one five asked what I thought
about this and in me calling it the rape
of my childhood well now you know now
there has not been a proper Ninja Turtle
thing that's existed since secret of the
use that third time-traveling movie that
never happened and that Ninja Turtles
live-action TV show that was kind of
like Power Rangers but kind of not that
had a fifth Ninja Turtle female
character it was a reptile with tits
figure that one out that never happened
and just the whole slew of failed
attempts trying to give the once
legendary franchise CPR over the course
of the past 15 years it's just never
stuck and I've heard whispers of a new
Ninja Turtles movie for years now I mean
at a point John Woo was gonna direct it
and it became a shitty CGI movie and
then just recently we get these glimpses
of the supposed new look at the new
Ninja Turtles and you know they look
kind of dark and sick and gritty and I
was like okay I'm on board with this you
know they kind of look like sketch C's
from the Dark Crystal but you know I
kind of liked it they they looked eerie
and then it was announced a couple days
ago that Michael Bay is producing it and
my childhood just got kicked in the junk
now the good news is apparently Michael
Bay Megan Fox they hate each other now
and she was kicked off of transformers 3
along with Jar Jar Binks so apparently
the three characters who never should
have had dialogue in transformers 2 will
not be in transformers 3 so the fact
that they hate each other that's good
for us because with Michael Bay
producing I do not think Megan Fox is
gonna be April O'Neill and Ninja Turtles
she'll just stick to being a [ __ ] and
Jonah Hex hey at least she's playing to
her strengths when choosing new
characters it's important the less she
talks the better in fact keep her on the
cover of Maxim magazine's as a mute life
will be good so what should Michael Bay
take away from all of this he probably
should know that he does single-handedly
have the ability to ruin a beloved 80's
franchise and even if he's probably not
going to direct Ninja Turtles I mean his
fingers are still in it you know so
Michael Bay from us to you here are the
rules in Ninja Turtles you were to have
no annoying ass parents no annoying ass
side characters that are made just to
appeal to children and defend black
people no pot brownies that apparently
wig parents the [ __ ] out in fact no
college scenes of any kind about that no
annoying ass government agents no forced
comedic dialogue that just feels out of
place just stick with what it is good
guys versus bad guys
the reporter who can act and looks good
just saying here it is when the writer
brings you a script that you just love
and you're like this is it this is Ninja
Turtles
send him back to shitcan it and rewrite
it then when he brings you another draft
of the script that you just hate that's
the one you're gonna film because that's
probably the one that'll be you know
good so what do you guys think about
this Michael Bay producing Ninja Turtles
good bad got to hear your thoughts on it
and if you don't know what Ninja Turtles
are we'll just rip on Michael Bay it's
always fun and if there's something
recent that's happened in the world o
entertainment you want to hear my
thoughts on it send me a comment I might
not get to all of them but still power
to the people a semi kind of sinister
[Music]